hello I'm Greg Sadler and I'd like to
talk to you a bit about YouTube channel
membership specifically to my channel
they're a way that people who like the
kind of content that I produce can you
know support the work that I do and they
can also get some nice perks or Rewards
or tokens of my gratitude in response so
it's kind of a back and forth or two-way
street you could say now if you're not
interested in Channel memberships you
don't have to get one because I put out
a lot of free content whether it's live
streaming like my amas or other things
along those lines or all the other
videos that I generate the half hour
Hegel the core concept videos all sorts
of stuff that are used by students and
professors and lifelong Learners all
over the world and I've been doing this
about a 11 years years or so so I've
generated who knows you know well over 2
000 videos that get used by a lot of
people something like
200 years worth of watching time so far
so clearly people like the content so if
you want to become a member there's
three different tiers that they have one
is called the silver one is called the
gold and one is called the Platinum you
know pretty ritzy stuff there and here's
what people actually get so at the
silver level there are custom badges
that you can use and also I think this
is a cooler thing custom emojis that we
created using you know myself as the
template and I also give priority to
people who are commenting at the silver
level you know I get tons and tons of
comments every day I try to respond to
as many of them as I can you get
priority at the silver level at the Gold
level you get all of those and early
access to selected videos and I'm going
to start rolling that out very soon and
I'll also include you in
updates so you know status updates
photos that not everybody gets to see or
read just people who are at that level
and then finally at the Platinum level
we have exclusive member only videos
that I'm going to get started on quite
soon member only live streams where you
know it's getting you know much more
interactive engagement with me and then
I'll give member shout outs as well now
like I said there's no obligation to do
any of this you can keep watching all
you want for free I've got tons and tons
of videos at this point you know over 2
000 that you can browse your way through
but if you would like to help support
the work that I am doing in this channel
let me say thanks in advance and every
little bit helps and contributes to the
work that I'm doing and you know I like
to give a little bit back to the viewers
if you want to get in on the exclusive
things uh become a member and you can
check it out you'll see the link below
for
um you know how to become a member and
some descriptions of all of this you can
also just go straight to the uh join
button or the membership part of the
channel and you'll find everything there
as well so if you're not interested in
becoming a member that's cool with me
you just keep on doing what you're doing
if you'd like to become a member thanks
so much for doing so and for supporting
the ongoing work that I do I've put in
more than a decade producing videos I'd
like to keep doing it for at least
another decade generating content that
people can use to further their
education online and you know learn
about philosophy literature history and
all the other fields that I cover